house Gumrah this man is pure pat let's
play some more evil within
what the hell you cereal you cannot add
FECA alotta with me our data we got a
map don't laugh
shucks bolt so you can shoot the ground
with it
who's making that nests who installs
[ __ ] like that to their house wow just
wow
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] what did I do I
mean it's a damn pretty room I gotta say
that at least oh should we really go in
here this is um oh oh well everything my
dad's better in the end breast Yee ovals
question yeah what do you think there's
gonna be three of them brah
there we go that's how you take them all
right sorry dude I'm gonna have to do
this little you see a line I'm check
number 12
does everyone be all the girls placement
mate
stimulation of a mental a sea of emotion
and memory
the fear center of the brain oh my god
I'm sorry okay so we have this thing
here fear isn't a too cool so I was just
lucky in the other one it should be here
oh sorry about that bruh I really am
I don't know what I'm doing but it I
feel dirty who comes up with stuff like
that seriously what is this our food oh
my god this is I just want to go home
and have some hot chocolate
oh [ __ ] I know no more we insane if you
only know how satisfying that look on
your faces did you have like this if you
lock me away
have we just ceased to exist out of
sight out of mind
you did you did didn't you
oh yeah we're never out of my mind I
hope you're proud of yourselves
oh my god this game is if the [ __ ] up
man
but I never really shaked oh god why did
I have to do that it's that that [ __ ]
again isn't it oh come on
all right I'm going [ __ ] that I'm
running no ha ha ow
oh Jesus that almost killed me
oh hello I got the juices running whoa
this is happening Oh almost a dam and a
boom shacka lacka awesome
what is this morefox a frequency
stimulation of cortical regions has
proven less than effective the subjects
scream and scream but they died much too
quickly now that's a bummer
tailored settings achieve better results
the only question that remains has which
regions to focus on fear hope consent
trust
three of these are pivotal but which
will open the way
drugs there's a hell of a drug wait what
stupid lamp don't judge me okay
I I think I'm going further but I don't
know is this gonna end I'm alone I also
did a leaf on it okay
long no long never knew Toby and let
their life get together okay
Jeff bloody soft Annabella they want
some chips and butter canned all right
not gonna die now all right I'm not
gonna die now this [ __ ] oh I love you
squeals that's adorable
we're back here wonderful all right yeah
let's check out the win down here brooch
I choose only one more and one more to
go
awesome that one goes in here
is this your opening no it isn't is it
Oh stupid pot nevermind you can never be
too careful in a place this this is my
favorite place so far looks the least
out of all [ __ ] up
yeah [ __ ] stealth approach I'm just
gonna try to hide from me huh is that
what you're trying to do not to my new
batch
yo ink stupid barrels always the barrels
always now what else would be in here I
must have missed something
what about in here what didn't they
didn't they didn't they didn't I that a
night
let's check in here this place must have
changers thank you go come to Papa poo
Oh God Oh God okay that's a nice bomb
don't whine no trouble now so I can stop
blue success red failure got it oh well
that was easy
so we can build like stuff out of them
that's kind of cool this [ __ ] opening
doors manually
all right I'm ready what's up Oh piano
but I love pianos what is that a book
two worlds separated by a jag chasm bub
faceless spectators mocking the tragedy
below helpless victims losing everything
on we found this one of the pieces at
least then we where we need both of them
where could the other one be who knows
these days a granade hundred years ago
awesome swagman its [ __ ] on you [ __ ]
okay well then we're just gonna have to
find the other one
what just happen why me oh my god stop
just stop let me alone let me alone I'm
gonna go home I want to go home I want
to go home I want to go home this is not
okay oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god
okay that part just freaks the [ __ ] out
of me man I have goose slippers on my
face right now okay
we have to find that other one I don't
have we've been here before no this is
new
alright this could be it I don't like
the look of you though gonna have to
whoa I don't like that if I [ __ ] up I'm
so [ __ ]
maybe it's up here I don't know
oh god that's definitely not dead stay
down stay down
alright alright alright alright let's be
friends just kidding I don't date dead
Navy it's just a thing
what don't stab me you're down my god
get a lot double killed that much that's
what I do just less like you there this
oh my god
yeah yeah we just have to find out the
code now good thing I have no idea what
the code is son of a [ __ ] maybe that's
it alright maybe there's a maybe that
you know there's the two paintings and
then there's the 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
11 oh so this is the other piece of the
painting 1 2
- and then there's a guillotine all
right you know what let's that's all I
got right now let's just go with that
rose I'm not the best at puzzles in my
life and my whatever but that could just
might be crazy enough to work
all right where is the thing wonderful
oh he's taking a little break don't
worry about it
there we go now we can play with these
hopefully I'm not wrong here Jing Oh
that's a nice approach what did you have
to do that was that really necessary
what an O God what it what who would
what what uh ah Shh
and neither one of you huh hello oh god
don't tell me
subject number fourteen test ADHD prices
temporary electro replacement see for
stimulation of the cingulate cortex okay
Hope Center the Hope Center well we're
about to penetrate that don't we hope is
up there a-sailing hope access improves
domination of the subjects will
domination isn't enough stay DNC Oh God
so
III don't even right now don't let I
don't want that guy again not that guy
again [ __ ] that guy again oh come on
it'll has not received the family's
usual donation this year and why would
they as the hospital been doing anything
or the up donation the Victoriano family
has always been a generous contributor
where are your parents
they have gone away when do you expect
them they're frightened Abe's there's
something you wish to discuss doctor I
came to inform you that the hospital
will no longer be able to provide you
with assistance materials your research
will very quickly disintegrate how dare
you come into my home and threaten me
uh what happened I thought they were
bells I thought they were he was like
encouraging him to do all kinds of weird
[ __ ] it's his fault you know I'm just
saying all right let's see what lies
beyond this [ __ ] up door about [ __ ]
time
agreed
oh so it's the pro-ice that's awesome
come on this corridor really what was
that don't do that don't look around
it's fine really
you know what on second thought maybe we
should get them don't we have any help
yeah we do oh god oh god oh god oh jesus
what some ice clean all the way what do
they do that'll cure for what I'm going
to do to you don't do a heel or steen
skin
No
what is that what did you do to piggy I
just don't want the girl again the girl
is the worst
alright let's go in here
hello that I don't like where this is
going right at us I really really really
don't but that's ok that's a pretty door
yeah damn it yeah
damn it Sammy I press that was the evil
with then hope you enjoyed this it's
super pumped for the actual dick game to
come out obviously we're gonna play that
as well so go ahead and leave a like if
you enjoyed this episode if you looking
forward to this series and hit the sky
comer today and I'll see Bruce in the
next one